par contre annoncé un déo efficacité 48
heures va merci c'est cool et des
chewing gum menthol ultrapuissant eux
merci à une chemise et a gardé le ticket
non jeu tout cas où si jamais l'envié
d'aller changer ou de même le rendre
tiens c'est moi qui l'ait fait pour toi
ô un collier de nouilles
mais c'est de la merde alors je t'ai
offert un action man à 200 balles et une
mauviette doom en pâte pour y à un
centime
je venais gueule des plumes ont pu
choquer j'ai été abandonné sur
l'autoroute comme une vieille crottes
pas cool une bd attends je vais faire un
petit passage bibliothèque municipale de
bagnolet à rendre le 8 janvier ouais
d'ailleurs tu peux le lire assez vite
ça m'arrange hockey mec c'est mon chien
ça ouais je sais mais au moins je me
suis dit que je serai pas déçu moi j'y
crois pas tu veux faire un ordinateur
éducatif et tu adores surfer sur
internet regarder des films ou même
jouer à des jeux vidéo grâce à
l'ordinateur décati tout cela est
impossible
c'est de la merde
pas internet pas de jeux vidéo plein
exercice comme à l'école et un écran en
noir et blanc
j'apprends à faire des additions j'ai
trouvé le synonyme de lui avec
l'ordinateur éducatif apprend sans
t'amuser
au sam amick il m'a envoyé une petite
carte avec un petit chaton trop mignons
ces adorables ya pas de chèque
y'a pas de chèques bat les couilles
alors canaux suivants
c'est le père matthew webb a parfois le
père noël j'ai annulé cadeau là c'est
annulé ouais moi j'attends la bretagne
surtout surtout les huîtres et le prix
du meilleur acteur dans la catégorie je
fais semblant d'aimer mon cadeau de noël
revient norman pour le coup d'autres
fromages etc sont brouillons les images
qu est ce que c est un couteau à fromage
merci merci j'adore le fromage en plus
ça tombe bien merci
c'est un très beau livre qui retrace
toute l'histoire des mérovingiens a
notamment souhaité ce moment où clovis
perd son glaive en pleine bataille
d'accord pas d'accord cliquez donc en
fait ouais
excellent c'est exactement le même
panneau qui adore la rue devant chez moi
c'est apparemment il est plus là c'est
un petit bond en ait que j'ai ramené de
mon voyage au japon
d'accord ils mesurent combien mange pas
il mesure 45 cm il pèse combien je sais
pas je dirais 500 grammes
c'est bon ça en vente sur ebay à ces
normes seco c'est un pin ça c'est un
symbole pin's d'alain la fameuse j'ai tu
la voulais j'ai fait graver son nom
dessus en lettres d'or si unison
collector unique au monde
mais j'ai acheté avec pour toi parce que
c'est mon pote ben moi aussi j'avais un
cadeau pour toi mais c'est pas cela ça
c'est autre chose gérer notre foi le
chercher c'est un cadeau un autre truc
mieux que toi ça me fait toujours un peu
de voir quelqu'un recevoir une bouteille
d'alcool pour noël si j'imagine pas du
tout le père noël préparés à ce genre de
cadeau nicolas tu as été sage cette
année alors je te mets une tête du sky 1
2 litre de vodka et un gros bout de
barrettes de shit de beaulieu à l'étoile
de noël michael
en tout cas le plus important à noël
c'est pas les cadeaux que c'est d'être
réunis ensemble alors une petite pensée
pour ceux qui malheureusement sont tout
seul cette année encore à noël
moi j'aimerais faire un petit cadeau
pour ceux qui malheureusement pas la
chance d'en avoir mais attention
roulements de tambour horrible
j'aimerais offrir tout simplement 10
places de spectacle mon spectacle norman
sur scène à ceux qui n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir des cadeaux on dit dans les
commentaires et puis je vous en offre
n'est pas par tirage au sort
voilà je jouais noël alors je vais vous
prendre un petit sirop de papaye bio
sans gluten est une clé usb 32 gigas si
possible compatible avec mon macbook pro
x